business insider was reporting it's a  terrible terrible news as a result of  the dobbs decision  zoomers are having less promiscuous sex  this is really bad they're thinking  about sex more they're deciding if they  like the person they're having sex with  there may be being a little reticent  there's a horrible horrible news you are  seeing a downstream cultural effect the  left talked about the metoo movement for  how many years time's up they talked  about a rape culture not incidents of  rape but a rape culture that is  pervasive  all of that is because of the sexual  revolution and a culture that encourages  promiscuous sex where those lines are  blurred blurred lines you're going to  have those situations where people don't  know where the boundaries are it  redounded entirely to the benefit of  dirtbag men it harmed lots and lots of  women and it killed a bunch of babies  and now that's over and that's a big win  for america can i just say